you can be tracked using Wi-Fi even with
GPS turned off with GPS you can use apps
like Google Maps Apple Maps and ways to
get to your destination hackers use
information from apps to spy on you
using the Google API they can get
information about the cell towers to
which your mobile phone is connected the
signal strength and the location of the
tower allow them to approximately
calculate the location of the phone this
is called mobile phone
triangulation with an increase in the
number of towers the accuracy of
determining coordinates
increases the same applies for Wi-Fi
when you connect to it it has a certain
signal strength using Google's
geolocation API and Wi-Fi Hotspot data
you can get your coordinates and the
malware wiffy Recon was created
specifically to search for a location
over Wi-Fi be careful and subscribe to
ssub